I forgot to ask you
um
if you had to fight against the bear
line gorilla or anaconda to the death
um which one would you choose and
would you be able actually to win
against any of them what beer
a lion
a tiger a tiger
oh a gorilla too gorilla you can go
gorilla
I'll probably choose the Anaconda
I see
was that I mean you're not allowed to
run away though so you're in a cage
do you have to kill
the Anaconda okay I said the other one
look I think I have no chance against
any other ones with Johnson I think I
have a tiny little hero against the
Anaconda
just waited out you don't you don't
think it's possible to beat
I just um
it it feels like technique can do
something against these animals but they
have so much strength so much aggression
you know that the real naked choke
translating to Portuguese is kill the
lion
so ever since I was a kid I always
thought that maybe if I get behind a
lion the real naked choke which you know
in Portuguese it says Mata Leon
so I always thought that that's the only
way to kill a lion but you know if
you're fighting against Allah you go
behind you put the real naked choke I
think you put him to sleep or the name
Mata Leon yeah it's like kill the lion
yeah someone came up with the name why
somebody must have maybe someone well
you don't fight with their life talk too
much there you go I I honestly do you
think also actually yeah you you
understand controlling positions do you
think like a animal like a gorilla or a
lion will shake you off if you had back
full you locked in well you say the one
that'll have the biggest chance of
staying there is the lion because she's
the thinner body yeah he's smaller than
a tiger I'll guess I think tigers are
bigger yes so so do you think they can
shake you off though I think I'll have a
bigger chance of staying against
Alliance back than any other animal
still not answering the question do you
think you have a chance
if I start on the back I start full
locked in full controls let's say it's a
small enough line you can actually have
a full oh that would guess so I mean I I
would like to believe so okay
well like Jessica said somebody must
have been able to do it